[Music]
ever since the release trailer for the
Nintendo switched back in October
details about the console have been
sparse until today at the press
conference Nintendo unveiled quite a bit
of information about the switch
including price release date and of
course a full rundown of the games that
will be available on the console it was
a six-course meal of a presentation
satisfying almost every Nintendo craving
that we've ever had so let's dig in
shall we Nintendo consoles have
historically launched at some
competitive prices and the switch will
retail for 299 dollars and ninety-nine
cents it's a little bit more expensive
than with the ps4 and xbox one are going
for right now but for a brand new
console it's a fairly reasonable price
and you'll have some time to save up
because the switch will be launching in
just a couple of months on March third
okay we've seen the prices we know the
launch date we finished our appetizers
and now it's time for the main course
Nintendo spend a lot of time during the
presentation outlining the games that
will be available for the switch on
launch day as well as once slated for
release later this year the first game
that they officially announced is one to
switch a game that forgoes any screens
in order to play and focuses on human to
human interaction using the joy Khan
controllers motion controls in a variety
of unique ways
[Music]
nintendo also announced arms a boxing
game that also uses the motion controls
using your characters extendable arms it
will offer some crazy-looking fights in
some crazy fun as well splatoon to a
proper sequel for the wii u squid based
shooter was revealed showing off new ink
guns stages and special weapons so get
ready to be a squid all over again it'll
be arriving for the switch later this
summer and Mario's back in a city with
real people wait hold on what's going on
[Music]
it looks like Nintendo is going a little
bit outside the box in Super Mario
Odyssey with Mario leaving the Mushroom
Kingdom and going on a worldwide
adventure we're gonna have to wait a
little while for this one though as it
will be coming to the switch this
holiday season Nintendo also teased us
with a short trailer for both Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 and Fire Emblem warriors as
well as some quick looks at a new Shin
Megami Tensei game and project octa path
traveller a new RPG by square enix there
were a few other games that they
highlighted that didn't have any footage
such as FIFA and a new game in the no
more heroes series but hold on to your
horses because intend to finally reveal
the release date of their big one yep
I'm talking about the legend of zelda
breath of the wild and they have
confirmed that it will in fact release
alongside the switch on March third and
on to dessert with most people's focus
in the last couple of months being on
the games and the price of the console
Nintendo reveal some pretty surprising
features about the switch during the
presentation we all know that we'll be
able to take the switch on the go and
Nintendo has confirmed that the battery
life will be roughly between two and a
half to six hours not too shabby if you
ask me they've also announced its online
plans for the console in an interesting
change for Nintendo it will be a paid
service much like PSN and xbox live and
hey there's also no region lock on the
switch so we'll be able to play games
from anywhere in the world on it
Nintendo also talked in detail about the
joy Khan controllers themselves
highlighting features that include a
gyroscope amiibo functions color options
and what they're calling an HD rumble
feature that will apparently be able to
simulate multiple ice cubes in a glass
at once
okay that's all they show it off during
the presentation but check out
Nintendo's website for even more
information on the console they've got a
rundown of the online services
controller prices and to look at even
more games like mario kart 8 deluxe so
check that out and keep it tuned to
gamespot for all the latest switch news
[Music]